This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to discuss something a little bit different. we're going to talk about what it means to be an attractive person, our fascination, our obsession with beauty, and why it is that we find some people more good looking than others, alongside the impact of phenomena like pretty privilege and the impact of beauty standards. This is an episode that I've wanted to do for a while, because I think a lot of us in our 20s, myself included, spend a lot of time thinking, worrying, judging ourselves based on whether or not we match up with
a version of what is conventionally beautiful. It's something that we cannot deny caring about. We are constantly aware, I guess, of some invisible standard of attractiveness, of beauty, of looks, of features that are going to make us more socially appealing. And I think at times we are too aware to the point that it really influences our behavior. We change certain things about ourselves, the clothes we wear, the hairstyles that we have, our makeup, even our weight, our physical form, our facial features through things like cosmetic surgery as a way to not only feel more confident, but I also think to conform to a lot of societal expectations and norms around beauty. I think at times that this comes at a really huge personal consequence,
where we are unable to see our worth beyond our physical appearance. We begin to see our bodies in very unrealistic ways or kind of refuse to feel good about ourselves unless we look a certain way on the day. And unless we conform to what the beauty standard is of the day or the month or the year. You know, are we trying to look like a Kardashian today or like Bella Hadid? Or some other model or famous image of what beauty is and should be. and I think that can be harmful.
And it's obviously on our minds a lot. A study published in Australia, literally just a few months ago, suggested that nearly a third of women in their 20s have considered or are considering cosmetic surgery. I won't lie. I'm in that boat. I have spoken to my friends about baby Botox or filler
or chin reduction surgery so much this past year more than I ever thought that I would. And I used to feel really ashamed that I didn't love my body enough to keep it the way that it was. But I've realized and I've come to recognize that our obsession with attractiveness is also highly universal. And as psychology will show us, very instinctual to our human nature. Part of human nature is a desire to be attractive because attractiveness symbolizes
so much more than just surface value looks. attractiveness has this unspoken and implied association with things like status and wealth, but also of course health, reproductive value, the quote unquote quality of our genetics. These are all characteristics that we are hardwired to value because they are associated with better life outcomes and a higher kind of place in the social hierarchy. If you want to think about it in a very rudimentary way, psychologists who kind of examine the social and the psychological impacts of beauty, they often explain why we find certain things attractive, why we are concerned with our looks based on our ability to reproduce, based on what they call our mating instinct. So some of these theories are of course a little bit outdated in the modern world, but it's been suggested that one of our primary drives as humans
is to basically just have children and to have the healthiest offspring possible so that they are more likely to survive and carry on our genetics. Part of having healthy children comes down to picking a mate whose own DNA background genetics is going to best match ours and create the kind of children, offspring, kids that are going to have a fighting chance. This is very, very evolutionary. Obviously, nowadays, we have so many different medical innovations and techniques and methods that it doesn't really matter if, you know, your child has certain little quirks about them
or certain things where they're not as healthy as they should be. like they're still going to survive potentially to old age. But back in the day when we didn't have medical care because we were like roaming the jungle, roaming the Sahara, picking the right partner who was going to give your kids the best chance of survival was really important. Obviously when we are making that decision, we cannot peer into someone's genetic blueprint and find out if they are healthy or not. We can't peer into their DNA and find out what kind of medical,
preconditions or predispositions they have, but we can look at their physical traits and kind of identify whether or not, A, these characteristics are indicative of better health, and B, would that make for healthier offspring who are more likely to survive? So the things that we typically see is beautiful, things like youthfulness, good skin, nice hair, tall, muscular, large eyes, they are actually all indicative of someone's almost capacity to survive and also of their health. That is why we find certain things attractive, not because they are more attractive in a really arbitrary sense, but because of how they help with our sense of security, our sense of survival, our ability to pass on our genetics. So the one I always think of is like why we find tall men more attractive. Like there
really isn't any reason other than a very biological, evolutionary reason, to have a preference for taller men if that is your preference. But previously, prehistoricly, someone who was taller may have been more athletic, may have been stronger, may have been more able to reach the fruit high up on the tree. Those were all big perks, big kind of pros when it come to producing healthy surviving children. Those factors are now, as I said before, not as important, but they are still part of our genetic blueprint. They are still part of our DNA. And it's interesting because the standard of what we find attractive is actually pretty consistent across populations, ages, genders, ethnicity, with only a few deviations, suggesting that really deep down
there is this like kind of profile or image of the perfect person. So in one meta-analysis, they looked at over 900 studies on this and they found that if they gave people a big group of different individuals from different backgrounds, different ages, different genders, all of those things, most people in these large groups would come to an agreement on who was the most attractive amongst this group, even if they themselves had different backgrounds. This strongly suggests that judgments of physical attractiveness are really hardwired into human genetics. They're also likely to be fixed at a really early stage in kind of our upbringing and
development. We actually devote entire portions of our brain to evaluating characteristics of attractiveness. They did studies on six-month-old infants, and what they found was that these kids, although they're only six months out of the room, they can't even speak yet, they look longer at the faces of adults who we would call objectively attractive. And they spend less time looking at faces of those who we would judge as not attractive. Because as we've concluded, it's not just about beauty, the social idea of beauty. It's about something very primal, an animal in our brain that has been programmed to pay attention to looks. The brain is actually such a good detector of beauty that it can
actually judge the appeal of a face before we are even aware that you've seen it. So when participants in a recent study were presented with an attractive and an unattractive face, they had only 13 milliseconds to look at them both. And from that, just very, very brief vision, they were able to judge which of these faces the average person would call more attractive. So they're not even consciously aware of the stimuli, and yet we are almost on an unconscious level able to pick up the certain features that make a person healthier, make a person more attractive, make a person more desirable when it comes to mating. So what are the sum of the features that we're kind of, we universally accept as being attractive
that we're looking out for? key elements that go into our appraisal of beauty on a very, very rudimentary primal level, are age and health as well as facial symmetry, body proportions, facial colour and texture, mainly to do with things like skin. Youth is obviously a major component when it comes to attractiveness. Older faces are judged as less attractive, less energetic, once again because of reproductive viability. So we do have this obsession with wanting to look younger
because we understand that looking younger means that we are more attractive to the average person because it indicates that our time to have children has not yet come to an end. This really explains like our obsession with Botox and youthful beauty routines and retinol and whatever else there is that is meant to keep us looking younger for as long as possible.
Facial and body symmetry are also a big thing that we instinctually look for. And I found this really interesting when I discovered this, because the reason why we like symmetrical faces is really fascinating. There are really small variables that can make it so that we do not have a symmetrical face. You could have a slightly wider jaw on one side or one of your eyes could be like a tiny fraction lower than the other one. one of your cheekbones might stick out just a wee bit more, a little dimple on one cheek. These are just small quirks that we may love in someone else and that we might find attractive. But what this science and the psychology is suggesting is that when we look at someone who has a symmetrical face versus an asymmetrical face,
our preference is always going to be for symmetry. Firstly, symmetry is good, is valued because it's easier to interpret the emotions of those who have this kind of bilateral symmetry. So basically it means that if you have someone whose face is kind of exactly the same on either side, you know exactly how emotions are going to be displayed compared to someone who might have small little differences that might warp how you would traditionally or are used to seeing emotions. It's also the fact that asymmetry, having a little bit of a difference, is kind of a sign of congenital or developmental defects. Not so much anymore, but in the past. They might be a sign of malnutrition or infection or indicative of a deeper genetic mutation. You know, those minor variations, like having a dimple, having like a slightly higher cheekbone, that is not going to have any functional consequences. They do not have a dramatic impact on our lives. But what we are
finding again and again is that symmetry is much more attractive. It is more highly rated as being associated with dominance and health and sexiness. Once again, because it comes back to the genetic desirability of a mate. Beauty perceptions obviously differ for men and women, particularly when we're talking about cisgender heteronormative men and women. And that's really where most of the research is being done because I don't know about the rest of the scientific community, but the psychology community is a little bit behind in recognizing kind of the diversity of genders and sex. But from what they've shown, when we look at things like facial hair, for example, that is indicative of higher testosterone levels. It's also associated with greater fertility and strength. So women are more
likely to prefer men who have those features or who have a muscular build or high cheekbones, not just because they're more sexually attractive, but because they might be a better long-term mate. And then when it comes to women and male preferences for women, often it's things like having large hips, having large breasts, having nice skin, having long hair because it indicates that you are going to be able to give birth to healthy. children and also that you have like you're getting good nutrition that you are healthy that you are taking care of yourselves these are just some of the features that we're looking for that a lot of people find attractive right and once again it's mainly linked to reproductive capacity viability
and i feel like we spend a lot of time here discussing that fact what we find attractive and why but i also want to investigate what are the consequences of of meeting that profile of attractiveness or not. You know, it's not all about mating and having kids. I think we are a bit more evolved nowadays to realize that not everyone wants to have children. But based on our conclusions, beauty standards are only important
because of how they relate to reproducing. If that's the case, you have this whole group of people who don't want kids, kids and yet they still really care about their looks. So we're kind of missing a part of the equation here. I think that is that we as a society implicitly understand and acknowledge that how we look, our beauty levels, our attractiveness levels, they are important for our social relationships and for how we are treated. A lot of that comes down to the concept of pretty privilege. Our acknowledgement that people who are perceived as more beautiful or as meeting beauty
norms are going to get better or preferential treatment. So there was a study conducted back in 2019 published in the Behavioral Science Journal. It found that throughout the world, attractive people show greater acquisition of resources and better treatment than others. and it's often those people that we celebrate and promote and see as beautiful, they follow a very similar formula. They are thin, they are white, they are young, they are cisgendered, they are tall, they have good skin, they have long hair. Not necessarily the everyday person and definitely not the only version of beauty. And you know what, let's point out the obvious before going any further, that is super unfair. It's unfair, it is an unfair world to live in, especially when the way that you look
really has nothing to do with how good of a person you are. It is genetic luck. It has nothing to do with your value as a person, how kind you are, how intelligent you are, how caring you are, and yet we cannot implicitly escape this privilege that exists all around us, whereby if you happen to match this profile of what is attractiveness, life just might be a little bit easier for you. So they've done studies on this and they've found that people who are appraised as objectively beautiful, they are paid more, they get considered for more jobs, they are seen as nicer, as more intelligent, more trustworthy. They even did this one quite recently and it was around employment and they found that if you are someone who is good looking, you make about 12% more than people who are
deemed less appealing. It's the same thing with real estate brokers. If you're more attractive as someone who works in real estate, you make a lot more money. Psychologists call it the beauty premium. Essentially, it is the income gap between attractive and unattractive people. And one study has suggested, one group of researchers suggested that this beauty premium, this income gap is comparable to the gap between genders or ethnicities. We have some idea of why that is, but just because we understand that it comes from this weird genetic blueprint preferences, offspring, whatever, it doesn't necessarily make us feel good. It doesn't make us feel better to understand that even though it's biology and it doesn't have, you know, much to do with us,
it's not in our control. It's still pretty unfair. It's also really interesting. to me because although we do have some really universal ideas of beauty, the standards around us are constantly shifting and impossible to meet. One week we need to look stick thin, the next week we're expected to look lean and muscular. After that, we're meant to have really big boobs and big butts. That is because beauty standards are social norms, meaning that they are socially constructed. A social construct is not only very likely to shift and change quite quickly, often with no reason, but it actually has no real meaning beyond the group in which it is enforced. Social constructs only have power if the group chooses to enforce them. They are literally
not real, but they do feel real because they are enforced in very implicit ways for example, limited clothing sizes at stores, limited shades of makeup, identical models in every advertisement. But the fact that they are a social construct means that they can be changed almost overnight or dramatically because they are derived from really the minds of millions of people, but then backed up by and reflected by industries who make money from your insecurity, who make money from selling us a new standard, a new product, a new version of how you should be. How is it that we are meant to keep up with those changing beauty standards that make it so
your looks have to be the center of your universe, kind of a constant source of attention? I think that that is really, really impossible, especially when we understand that we will be validated by society if we are conventionally attractive. All of us want to be accepted, of us want preferential treatment. All of us want to be treated well. And what beauty standards and pretty privilege is really telling us is that you can have that life. This can all be unlocked for you if you just conform to how we would like you to look. That has a lot of consequences for our mental health, our social health, our emotional health. So how do we kind of break free from these expectations and this pressure and just be happy with who we are beyond our physical appearance? We're going to
going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. L.S. Correct? I doctored the test once.
It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news. at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The problem with beauty standards and the pretty privilege that comes along with it is twofold.
Firstly, it teaches us that our value is entirely derived from our physical appearance. rather than the contents of our character and our soul and our personality. Secondly, it says and it shows us and it ingrains in us that we need to change in order to be accepted. That leads to a lot of very deeply rooted dissatisfaction with our bodies, with how we look, and this misconception that our lives would be better if we just looked a certain way or fixed something about ourselves. I see this all the time in my own behavior, in the behavior of those around me, and it's so upsetting to think how many of us believe that if we just lost some weight, we'd be able to find love, or if we fixed our skin, we would be liked more by people that we work with or people around us
or people on the street. If we just touched something up there, altered something here, we would be more successful. It is never-ending, because I think when you start believing this myth, sold to you by a society obsessed with beauty that changing your appearance will somehow change the quality of your life, you will always find something else to be unhappy about or to not like about yourself. It's why we now see these terms for people who are addicted to plastic surgery or body modifications. It's why we're seeing rising numbers of body dysmorphic disorders and eating disorders. Harvard University even published a paper on this recently
suggesting that when we see our value as being determined by beauty, this translates into self-objectification. And that negatively impacts the treatment we feel we deserve, especially for women, where when we begin to see ourselves as an object that can be admired, that looks beautiful, we kind of start to minimize these other aspects of our identity and ourselves that are more important, self-objectification is associated with decreased political activism, less assertiveness, poorer workplace performance, because when we conform to an idea that beauty is our only value in the world that we need to look a certain way, what that basically means is that your accompanying idea of personhood and personality is restricted. It becomes less multi-dimensional. You don't need to
be intelligent. You don't need to be creative or assertive. You are merely something that is nice to look at, which we know is entirely incorrect. We are incredibly nuanced, well-rounded, deep individuals. But when we form an obsession with our looks and needing to fit a certain standard in order to be accepted, that really just becomes the highlight. It becomes the only thing we can focus on. So I want to offer a few reminders here for those moments when you're buying into the beauty standards, the pretty privilege of the world. Number one, there might be one standard of beauty that is most common, but that doesn't mean that beauty is a singularly defined thing. As the saying always goes, beauty is in the high of the beholder and the things that we might
see as flaws, others might see as kind of really beautiful parts of our tapestry as a human or a really attractive quirk. I think sometimes with phrases like that, we think that they've just been developed to make us feel better. But I'm always surprised by how much truth there are in these like everyday metaphors or idioms. So research is actually suggested that beauty is in fact in the high of the beholder. There is a preference for certain physical traits, but also it is our individual life experiences that leads us to find certain people more attractive than others, not just our genetics, not just our DNA. It's why your best friend might be like absolutely smitten with someone and you think they're like a solid three.
It's why we have different types. It's why we find some celebrities unattractive. Because life experiences are equally important here. It is about environment. It's about how much we value things like uniqueness, who our friends are dating, who we have dated in the past, what our culture is promoting as attractive, even what our parents look like. And that is a whole other chapter of psychology that I don't think we have time to get into. But essentially, some people theorize that we actually prefer partners who resemble our parents. And that is super weird. Some people say it's true. A lot more people say it's false and a little bit delusional. But I think it's evidence to show that it's not all about biology in these moments. It also is about how we have been
raised, how we have been conditioned to see beauty, and also the kind of deviations in that as well, such that even if you don't feel conventionally attractive, there is someone out there who's looking at you being like, I think that they are the most beautiful person in the world. You know, I used to have this, like, real deep hatred for this mole I had on my face. I used to Google, like, skin removal places, like, once a day, at least. And it's so interesting because my current boyfriend loves it. He's like, that is so cute. You can just never tell what someone is going to find beautiful about you that you might actually
find really unattractive because, once again, you can choose to conform and try and fit into someone else's version of a perfect body and a perfect face and whatnot. But when you do that, you also reduce your individuality in the process. And I think that individuality is what people ultimately love the most about you. My second reminder, and I think it goes without saying, but your appearance really is the least important thing about you. Your body is going to change as you age as you go through certain life events, but what will hopefully not change is the contents of who you are and how authentic and true to yourself you really choose to be. I'm always reminded of this Roald Dahl quote. He did this book, children's book called The Twits, and in it he says,
a person who has good thoughts cannot be ugly. You can be the most hideous person out there, but if you have good thoughts, if you are kind to other people, these will shine out of your face like sunbeams and you will always look lovely. I truly believe this. Kind people can never be unattractive because they have shifted beyond thinking about themselves only on the singular dimension of appearance and have a holistic view of their character, what they bring to the world, how they treat others, how they treat themselves that is so much more important. Additionally, something I like to remind myself when I start to kind of think too much about my looks and start picking at things, start Googling random surgeries in Turkey, is that some of the greatest,
smartest, most valuable people in this world do not meet the profile of what is attractive. People like Einstein, Steve Jobs, Mother Teresa, I don't think they could have done what they'd done, if they spent all that time worrying about their physical appearance more than their vision for the future. And I think it goes to show that in a world that really wants to teach you and really wants to enforce this philosophy that your looks are really, really valuable and really important and should be a big focus. There are thousands, millions of people who aren't thinking about that and who are thinking about how they can actually contribute to the world in a really meaningful way. and if they decided that they would rather focus on beauty and attractiveness,
we would miss out on a lot of amazing inventions, a lot of amazing changes in this world. Number three, my final reminder, we can say all that we want about beauty standards and what makes someone attractive from kind of an evolutionary biological standpoint. But time and time again, what trumps attractiveness is confidence, much like kindness, I think. Confidence has this ability to always make you the most attractive
person in the room. And there's a science behind this. When you believe in yourself, when you are self-assured, when you know who you are, that kind of radiates outwards. It makes you appear more attractive to others. And it's this energy that a lot of people often call the glow, right? this like magnetic golden aura. And in one study conducted by the Society for Personality and Social Psychology, they recruited a bunch of people and they had half of them fake confidence in these make-believe dating situations. And they found that these individuals who kind of faked it till they made it were rated higher in romantic attractiveness and just overall desirability again and again and again. Additionally, a lot of the things that we inherently kind of
genetically desire in a partner are really difficult to observe directly unless you actually take time to get to know someone. Things like intelligence, drive, social status, physical ability, personality, they are kind of things that we understand about ourselves, but other people don't understand about us. However, when you are confident, a lot of of people around you will assume that there is a reason to that confidence because you do have an actual sense of value. I think, I hope that makes sense, but I guess what it says is you don't have to, these people don't have to question whether you have value, whether you're worth knowing, whether you're worth dating, whether you're worth investing in, because you already know it. And so
they're more likely to believe you if you believe in yourself. I think that just goes to show that beauty is obviously not just skin deep. It's so much more nuanced and psychological. and emotional and our preoccupation with it is also probably going to be causing us more harm than good whereby the more we become fixated on changing things the less confidence we have so the less attractive we kind of become when we reframe our perspective and take physical appearance off a pedestal we feel so much more free to not have to perform and we can worry about pretty privilege and beauty standards as much as we like, we can acknowledge that the world is really designed for a small group of people. But each day, you also get to make a choice about whether you want to spend
your time thinking about this and trying to conform and spending money to look a certain way, or whether there's something else that is going to be more valuable that you can do with that time. How many hours are you wasting, fixating on something that? really isn't a true marker of who you are. How many minutes do you spend thinking like, my makeup doesn't look great, it looks a bit cakey? No one is really noticing that. And if they're making a step judgment based on that small aspect of who you are, that is highly superficial and it has nothing to do with you. So it's kind of like a bit of a balancing act here. What are you giving up by spending time thinking about this and what could you gain by spending that time thinking about
something else, thinking about how you can give back, thinking about your goals, thinking about your dreams, thinking about other people and how you can make them happy, how you can make them feel loved. There's one more exercise that I really want to share when it comes to feeling a little bit weighed down by beauty standards, pretty privilege, all of that, and that is a self-love, self-gratitude checklist. list. This involves writing down 10 things that you love about yourself that have nothing to do with what you look like, whether that is your creativity, how thoughtful you are, that you're strong, kind, a good cook, a loving daughter, a loving sister. I think we have been conditioned into seeing ourselves only as other people see us, which is through the lens of obviously
physical appearance. But when we actually break down that facade and really examine who we truly are if all of those things were taken away, we are able to get more in touch with the core of our true self and actually do something with that, do something valuable with all that time. I would also say what you consume is what you believe. So if you are constantly being exposed to only one type of individual on social media, on TikTok, on Instagram, you will course are going to have a very limited sample for what the average person truly looks like. It is one of the mechanisms by which beauty standards become indoctrinated and continue to control and influence us. Social media is very, very powerful. It is almost a way of learning what
society wants from you through the kind of content that you're exposed to. So I would really encourage you to diversify who you follow, really question why these. models and people look the way they do, how attainable that really is. What would you be giving up to be that person to look a certain way? And is it really worth it to just conform? Just so that people like you more, maybe. I'm starting to believe that it really isn't worth it, especially since when you try and fake being another person, someone that you're not, when you give up your very much individual unique beauty, you actually miss out on meeting people who are really, really, have just loved the real you, and I think that's such a shame. So one final disclaimer, I don't want
this to come off as like an admonishment of beauty, or seeing the need to take care of ourselves as a bad thing, or, you know, not sometimes benefiting from the confidence boost of looking really good and wearing makeup and having your nails done and your hair done. This is kind of by no means permission to criticize people who do experience pretty privilege or who are conventionally attractive. I think obviously empowerment comes in so many forms and some of that might come from changing our physical appearance. But I also think it's important to examine the societal influence that sometimes leaves us feeling obligated, that we need to meet conventional beauty standards in order to achieve some level of happiness or to be accepted or to be treated well.
when we feel shame in that sense, shame for just being who we truly are, nothing good really comes from that. So you can still accept that beauty standards have a role in our lives and that there are certain things that maybe do align with the implementation of beauty standards that you enjoy. Like I said, getting your nails done or investing in a really nice outfit or following trends, that is still totally fine. As long as it doesn't feel like necessary, as long as it doesn't feel enforced. as long as it doesn't feel like if I don't do these things, my life will not be as good as I want
it to be. So I really hope that you've enjoyed this kind of more rambly episode. Honestly, it's just been something on my mind. I've just been really considering attractiveness recently, really been like looking at people on the street and being like, you're attractive, I can tell. Why is that? Why do I want to keep looking at you? Why do I keep looking at myself in the mirror. Why do I keep picking at my skin, picking it little things on my face or my body that I just don't quite like? Where does that come from? So I hope that this has been interesting, fascinating, enlightening that you have at least learnt something. And if you haven't learned something, I hope that it's just left you feeling a little bit better, a little bit more encouraged by the
fact that you are not the only one who was thinking about beauty in maybe a dangerous, toxic way. I think it is very universal in our 20s, something that we should discuss more, something that we should be more open about, that this is not an isolated issue, all of us are consuming very similar content, feeling very similar things about what society expects from us in terms of looks. So thank you so much for listening to today's episode. As always, if there is a friend who needs to hear this, please feel free to share it with them or leave a five-star review wherever you were listening. make sure you are following us so that you know when new episodes come out.
And we are still taking episode suggestions. We're always taking episode suggestions. So if there's something that you want us to speak on, want us to look into, want us to understand the psychology of for you, please follow me at that psychology podcast and shoot me a message. And I'll chat to you over there. As always, have a lovely week. We will be back next week with another episode.
2%. That's the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on the Look Back at it podcast For 1979 That was a big moment for me
84 was big to me I'm Sam Jay And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick a year unpack what went down And try to make sense Of how we survived it
With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hill On the 80s It was a wild I mean It was a wild year
I don't think There's a more important year for black people Listen to look back at it On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcast Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games.
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the I-Hard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused
of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.